how long did it take before
you know once l ron hubbard died and
miscavige
became known as this leader and
and how did you become like his
right-hand man or like the head
of that special affairs organ part of
the company you're part of the
organization well it's sort of a long
story but
the the the beginning of it is
that i was chosen by miscavitch
to participate in what was
a series of actions to dismantle what
was called the guardian's office
and the guardian's office was the
precursor to the office of special
affairs
okay and that guardian's office was set
up by hubbard by hubba
and his wife mary sue hubbard was the
head of the guardian's office
okay and i told you earlier about this
raid that the fbi did
in 1977 and all those documents
the the result of that was the the
federal government
prosecuted mary sue hubbard and ten
other leaders of the guardian's office
they ultimately pled guilty and all went
to federal prison
for infiltrating the government for
stealing documents from the government
for
bugging the officers of the irs and the
doj
and i mean it was a massive massive
operation the largest infiltration
and spying operation ever against the
united states government
and the
ultimate outcome of that was that
hubbard decreed that the guardian's
office
including his wife had been traitors
and that they had you know messed up so
badly
that they had to all be gotten rid of
and
so it was put in
you know on the plate of miscavitch to
do that and where was hubbard during all
this
he was hiding hiding literally
he disappeared in the middle of the
night he drove off
in a car with two people from la quinta
originally he went to reno nevada
and lived in a motel and then
when things seemed to be safe he sort of
came back
and lived in hemet which is near the
the golden era productions property
which became the international sort of
headquarters of scientology
in riverside county california but then
when things heated up there
and he thought that he was going to be
subpoenaed or someone was going to
catch him he went
first to newport beach and he drove
around
in a bluebird bus motorhome for a
a whole bunch of time traveling around
incognito
and then bought a ranch near creston
california which is
north of santa barbara okay and
lived under an assumed name with a long
beard and long hair
there for until he died
wow miscavitch
meanwhile had you know we had
gone and disbanded
the guardian's office but as i said
replaced it with the office of special
affairs
and that was in 1981
and because of my participation in that
i ended up sort of moving into the
office of special affairs
and then rising in the ranks of the
office of special affairs until i became
the head of it
okay so this is so crazy
how does it feel to you now i mean
you were once a head of special affairs
which was in charge of dealing with
people like who you are right now
so you're considered right now you are
considered one of the biggest threats to
scientology
is that right absolutely yeah they
devote a lot of time a lot of money a
lot of private investigators
a lot of uh websites a lot of smear
campaigns
to me and leah remini we're like number
one and two
on the hit parade of scientology and
uh so how does i mean knowing what you
know because you were the head of that
and you obviously saw everything that
went on like the top
tier of the organization as far as
handling people like yourself
um how does that make you feel now being
one of the
the number one people who are outspoken
about this
um well honestly i feel like i have a
responsibility to do it
i feel like i have a responsibility to
all the people
who have been
abused by scientology and will continue
to be abused by scientology
i feel like you know there probably
isn't anybody else
in the world who has the
insight and the knowledge that i have to
be able to dissect what happens
and expose the truth about what really
is going
on you know that is coupled with
the you know how the hell did i
not how the hell did i not
get this why did it take so long right
like i'm not um
i'm not stupid but i was
for a very long time and this
is what is so um
so sinister about scientology
is ultimately if you walked down to the
the spiritual headquarters of
scientology in clearwater there
and spoke to those scientologists
you would find generally that they are
nice people
right they're not wackos they're not
like you know spouting
crazy standing on a street corner
the world is ending with holding
signs they're like normal people that
live sort of apparently normal lives
but if you poke around in into
their how they view the world they have
a very distorted view of
of the world and
and they will do things that
one wouldn't imagine that you could get
someone like that to do
it with the idea that it is helping
or protecting scientology and
if you can convince someone that
scientology is the answer to man's
problems
and the only hope for mankind and
the only path to spiritual freedom
people will do things that you wouldn't
expect that they would
be willing to do in order to protect
that
and scientologists you know that's why
larry wright his brilliant book going
clear
is subtitled scientology the prison of
belief
because it's a mind prison it
it you get sucked in
with the good ideas and what are
apparently the
good intentions of scientology
and gradually start to believe
this twisted world view that there
is an evil conspiracy of psychiatry
and medical doctors and big pharma
and governments who are seeking to
control
and enslave mankind and that the only
hope for mankind is scientology
and if you ask any one of those normal
looking people
walking down the street in clearwater
yeah whether
what they just say the word to them
listen uh tell me about psychiatry
you will get a blithering idiot
rant from them about psychiatry of the
enemies of mankind
they're destroying people they're
they're electric
shocking them they're doing pre-frontal
lobotomies they're sticking ice picks in
their eyeballs
they're doing this they're doing that
like this is
the the us versus their mentality that
is
absolutely hammered in to
every scientologist in the world and
people like me or reporters for
the saint pete times you know now tracy
mcmanus
we're all if not
just as evil we are the tools
of the evil we have become
the you know satan's
satan's bag men who
are doing the work of
psychiatry and big pharma to
seek to eradicate scientology because
scientology
is the only
effective uh foil
against their evil and if you if you
danny if you go look you will see
scientology has said that i'm being paid
by big pharma
i'm a spokesperson for the psychiatry
for psychiatry leah remini and
like anybody is this and this is
the the crazy mindset that lies
just beneath the social veneer
of the normal looking scientology people
i